good morning Hank it's Monday September
12th my posters have arrived so
yesterday I took a walk in the woods
with Henry in the Yeti Henry and I
practiced words will you say tractor you
say nerd fighter pretty good can you say
happy so we walked down to the White
River and for the longest time Henry
just stood there and watched the water
flow downstream I think he was trying to
figure it out like what is this made out
of what does it do why does it always go
in the same direction anyway we stay
down there for a long time and then we
went to a playground for me September
11th is always a good day to spend with
family because I'm always reminded on
that day that we're only here for a
little while that we only have so long
to play in the dirt and ask questions of
rivers Hank it seems to me that one of
the points of being alive is that we get
to pay attention we get to both
participate in and observe this weird
universe that is simultaneously like
stunningly elegant and completely
heartless just like all your
ex-girlfriends oh come on you can't just
like zoom in make a joke Andrew Matt
that's rude okay I'm trying to make a
moving point here this is not a jokey
joke V to go back to signing sewing some
nerdfighters were put off by your video
on Friday they felt like you didn't talk
about 9/11 directly enough or with
enough seriousness I definitely found
your video much less offensive Ben say
Budweiser's 9/11 commercials but there
was something weird about it and
yesterday while I was walking in the
woods with Henry in the Yeti I kept
thinking about it and eventually I
started thinking about maps like if you
want to render the planet in two
dimensions you are forced to distort it
you have to pick North is up or north is
down you have to squeeze the continents
this way or this way or this way all
year long we've been talking about how
the truth resists simplicity Hank I
agree with everything you said about
memory and 9/11 and terror but like any
map it was distorted and insufficient so
with my math last week about the Great
Gatsby but the 9/11 map is much more
like emotionally and psychologically
charged but I want to make something
clear to you and to nerdfighteria the
maps that we make with our vlog brothers
videos will always be distorted and
insufficient but the great thing about
nerdfighteria is that Hank and I are not
the only nerdfighters there are
thousands of us working together to
build the best most accurate maps we can
collectively draw what's interesting and
important about online communities in
general and nerdfighter in particular is
that this community works to improve and
enhance our Maps through YouTube
comments and on Twitter
and on tumblr and at the ning and in
your pants when they are attacked which
unfortunately they still are sorry about
that we're working on it and ideally
together as a community we end up making
better maps than any of us could make a
loan we call each other to pay attention
in short nerd fight area we're in the
business of reminding each other to be
awesome and I would argue that business
is good Hank I will see wait I forgot
about larger lineup mom's gonna kill me
if I don't mention North Carolina Hank
next month I will be speaking and
signing in Asheville North Carolina as a
fundraiser for my parents hometown
library all the proceeds will go to the
library tickets are 10 bucks there's
more info in the doobly-doo okay now I
will see you on Wednesday